est-ce que ce compteur va impacter la
facture d'électricité et la répondante
assénant la réponse elle est claire
c'est non mais c'est pas ça sexy la
gratuit laïb ô combien à 130,25 euros
par an c 130 euros sont intégralement
financée par enée 10 sociétés
entreprises de service public qui a la
mission en france d'amener l'électricité
j'ai 35 millions de clients et cette
mission nous l'horizon depuis maintenant
plus de 70 ans est en fait et en fait
pourquoi est-ce que ce conteur il
n'impacte pas la facture d'électricité
des clients il n'y aura pas de hausse de
la facture comme ça dans la mesure où
ces six mois c'est la vraie question est
la vraie question si c'est pourquoi un
compteur qui est dans la vraie question
c'est ce que tout le monde dit sur les
réseaux je vous jure pourquoi il était
gratuit et maliens il vaut 130 euros il
ne vaut pas 130 euros alors elle ne vaut
pas beaucoup ce que ces 130 euros que
vous considérez cette aînée disques et
les finances simplement laissez moi
juste une minute pour l'expliquer pas
d'accord effectivement valérie a raison
globalement ça coûte autour de 130 euros
par compteur x 35 millions de clients
c'est à dire autour de 5 milliards
d'euros commente ses finances et ses
financée par les économies que nous est
né dix sociétés de services publics y
acheminer l'électricité allons réaliser
à partir de 2022 sur nos frais à nous
sur notre fonctionnement sur nos
investissements parce que le réseau sera
de meilleure qualité
nos couvents baissé par exemple nous
n'aurons plus à nous déplacer chez vous
pour relever votre compteur ce sont 64
millions de déplacements annuels qui
seront évités on n'aura plus à se
déplacer pour mettre en service
électricité
on vous amène à gérer quelque part yves
ayant fait ses économies sur les 21
agréées
vous auriez pu ces économies sur les 20
années qui arrivent vont servir à
rembourser à ses 130 euros donc je vous
le dis très clairement et 20 millions
c'est faux la facture ne va pas y avoir
d'augmentation lié au cas probable sinon
demandé il faut vraiment avoir une est
ce que oui ou non parce que je rappelle
on parle de nous on s'est quand même le
ministre l'industrie à l'époque c'est
eric besson a utilisé l'argument de la
gratuité pour que tout le monde mérite
naftal chez soi la question c'est est ce
que oui ou non on va nous retirer 130
euros un moment donné pour payer ce
compteur c'est ça ne sais pas quoi être
la réponse à une autre question monsieur
ces noms précis à mais formidable vous
retirer 133 on a là rien pas pourquoi
vous avez été serré 5 milliards alors
c'est 5 milliards empruntés de l'argent
si c'est pas pour nous prendrons le
redis c'est 5 milliards
il a fallu entre 2016 et fin 2021
d'accord installé 35 millions de
compteurs c'est l'époux amérique
alors oui certes mais si j'ai tenté un
jeu blanc c'est même le président de ses
mythes francs capitaux qui me dit mon
frère où le compteur a un impact sur la
facture à la campagne chez moi c'est un
cauchemar
oui bien sûr mais j'aimais aussi la
consommation est calculé sur les avances
était sous la moyenne est maintenant
c'est sûr les heures pleines
oui non cela changera votre contraignent
à votre feuille si c'est faux c'est une
jeune bressan savez aujourd'hui au jour
on parle là il ya sur les 35 millions de
compteurs prévu 32 ont été installés et
apparemment oui et laxatives ayant
mesure la satisfaction de nos clients
après la pause aujourd'hui nous avons un
taux de satisfaction de 90 points cela
varie mais c'est vrai c'est grave et on
et sa fausse alors c'est moi coupée lors
d un vrai sujet de roland ce qu'on a ne
sont payés mais c'est vrai qu'elle a
raison ce sondage
il a été réalisé à cela quand on a dit
aux gens je vous aime gratuite aux gens
on va arriver à vous mettre un truc
savez gratuit oui bah moi je suis
content allez payer le mettais en
plusieurs même si vous voulez un sûr
mais quand on vous dit que c'est 30 ans
130 euros là je pense que le sondage si
vous leur faites il va être plus
compliqué jradi - harcelée pour
l'installer en disant en gros vous payer
sans vous allez payer 92 donc pourquoi
pas et si vous le faites pas ça va pas
vous allez payer moi or vous vous dites
finalement vous payer sans madame
aujourd'hui mais vous allez continuer à
payer 100 or soit disant le linky c'est
pour faire des économies d'énergie
donc en fait si je paye la même chose ça
veut dire que quelque part je paye la
wii alors il ya deux sujets merci de
cette question parce qu'elle est
vraiment intéressante
est-ce que ça va est-ce que
truffaut tennis mais sinon dans la
pénitence aller première question est ce
que ça va peser sur ma facture
l'installation du compteur la réponse
avec carel et net c'est non la deux le
deuxième sujet que vous évoquez c est ce
qu avec ce compteur je vais pouvoir
faire des économies sur ma facture
la réponse c'est oui parce que grâce à
ce contrat de nouvelles vont en fait oui
exactement tiens je vous montre un truc
là c'est l'application il est 10 à mes
côtés mais tous les fournisseurs
d'électricité on te la mets ont une
application nous rend son application
[Applaudissements]
ça y est
sans quitter des 10 vous venez chez nous
ça dépend l'argent alors ça c'est mon
espace client perso on voit ma
consommation d'hier et on voit aussi que
par exemple d'une journée sur l'autre
j'ai consommé 20,8 pour cent de moins
que la veille et je peux le faire par
semaine je peux le faire par moi je peux
le faire par saison qui a diminué
ouais mais là c'est un croc marc c'est
quoi ça c'est un espace qui me
permettrait un mot ce que je consomme au
jour le jour et en faisant ce faisant ça
bien je peux mieux maîtriser ma
consommation et je peux donc si je le
souhaite faire réduire ma facture c'est
moi qui les quais les discours laurent
bili c'est tout l'enjeu c'est la loi
mais l'essai l'ademe bernard vous
connaissez la dream c'est la chance de
la transition écologique
l'ademe a fait une étude qui montre que
on peut gagner jusqu'à 10 %
ça fait juste 530 euros il sort tout bas
là est ce qu'à un moment va nous faire
est ce qu'on va nous prélever centre
ambri il ou non sinon non mais alors
histoire de doux entre ses marques pages
où ils sont ils sont financés je vous le
redis ça dansait avec les économies que
nous ils disent nous allons réaliser
pour moi